Wow, that was a lot of feedback.
>> That was a lot of feedback, but
very good, constructive feedback.
>> Yes, good constructive feedback.
>> You know,
we found some issues that we knew about,
we found some issues that
we didn't know about.
One thing that strikes me here though is
that maybe we went a little overboard
on producing high fidelity mocks.
>> Yeah, we definitely did,
because we're going to need to
change a lot of these things.
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> And man, I spent so
long getting this little plus, or
this little check marks to work right.
I spent so long getting these fabs up.
Wasted hours.
>> Yeah, I think that we probably
could have dialed it back just a bit,
we probably could have gone with
some wire frames to suss out some of
the details that we were looking at.
Particularly when we talked to Hugh and
we talked to Parima,
we talked to them a little bit about
fab placement, things like that.
Perhaps we could have done
that with a wider frame.
>> Yeah, I think we could of.
And I think that would have saved us a
lot of time, because we could've gotten
this feedback faster and then not had
to lose as much work as we're going to.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
One of the things we were sweating is we
were talking about some of these mocks
too is like the color and
position of some of these things.
And I think that was largely
irrelevant to the feedback that we got.
So I think that maybe some of
those discussions could have
waited until later in the cycle.
>> They could have.
Some of those things, some of
the design issues are things that came
up, like-
>> Yeah.
>> We had the check box.
That we asked people to
check off these apps.
And Parema was able to find the little
check box here very quickly but
Hugh could just not find that there was
something in this app for to-do list.
>> Yeah.
That's right.
You know, I did find it interesting too,
that we got contradictory feedback in
that regard from both participants.
They wanted to look at the home screen.
Hugh felt strongly that he
wanted to see past events or
completed events, where as Parema didn't
feel that she wanted to see them.
She really want to see that be
as clean and clear as possible.
>> Right.
>> So I think we probably should
start annotating some of this stuff.
>> We should.
>> I think that one of the things we're
going to have to do is probably dig into
this screen a little bit.
And we're probably going to have
to add a stronger affordance for
task completion.
>> And yeah, it's clear that
even if we had intended for
the tasks to be swipeable here,
that's not intuitive.
Yeah, let's get you
some post-it notes too.
>> Yeah.
>> because we're going to take a lot
of notes here,
because we're really going to have
to focus on the next iteration here.
We really need to settle in on
a specific interaction, so that we can
make sure that the next round of testing
we get a really cohesive flow and
that our users really
understand that clearly.
>> Right.
>> So task completion was one thing
and the other thing we talked about
was whether or not we actually need
a strongeraffordance here for
completing tasks.
>> This is a heads up
display screen though.
>> Mm-hm.
So it is a heads up display screen and
we had intended it to be sleek and
not have all of these
extra things on it.
>> Yeah.
It's an at a glance type thing.
>> But if we also, we had decided
originally that this was going to be
sort of equally a calendar app and a to
do app and so both those things should
be doable from the home screen from
whatever we screen we land people on.
>> Well, actually Hugh had some
interesting feedback there, though.
>> Mm-hm.
>> He was confused as to whether or not
this a calendaring app or a to-do app.
>> Right.
>> We initially set out with the intent
of doing, I think, a mash up of both.
>> Yeah.
>> But
he was really confused because it didn't
seem to be any task management here.
There was, no what are we doing?
>> That's true.
>> There's a lot of who,
what, and where.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I'm sorry, who, where when.
But now what.
>> Yeah.
>> We're really missing
that what aspect.
>> We are, and
that's a thing that we just completely
missed in the design process.
We have options then to address that,
we can either say okay,
we need to re-emphasize that.
We need to have these big,
big check boxes here.
>> Absolutely.
>> Maybe even actually this shape here,
just pasted in,
as the way of doing it,
because our icon is a check box.
That is a thing that we clearly
have in the design up here.
But it's not a thing that we
have in the design down here.
Or we could do something
like change this icon,
make it just a calendar again.
And that's,
it's addressing a different problem, but
it's one that we've already
addressed pretty well.
>> Well, but the thing that we really
wanted to go after here was that strong
marriage between to-do and calendar.
And so I feel like if we abandon
the to-do aspects of the app,
then maybe we're not holding true to the
true promise of what we intended to set
out to do.
>> Right.
>> I do like your suggestion of re-using
the app icon a little bit more.
Hugh gave us some interesting feedback
that he felt the affordance here for
the checkbox needed to be stronger.
He missed it when he first looked at.
Pradema also had some issues with it.
We were talking about these gray circles
not being a strong enough affordance for
a checkbox, I'm sorry.
So I think we need to really
strengthen this stuff.
>> Right.
We can strengthen that
by making it larger,
we can strengthen that by
making it square, because
again I expect radio buttons to be round
and check boxes to be square usually.
>> Yeah.
One of the things that just came to mind
is that perhaps we can take just this
one screen and do a couple of
iterations on that one screen and
give those to some users for
some very directed feedback.
>> Right.
>> On those specific elements.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Do they feel
good about using this check
box as that affordance?
>> Right.
>> Will they pick up on the fact that
it is a way of completing the task?
>> Right.
So you're saying we can do user testing
on just iterations of a specific
screen rather than the entire flow.
>> That's right.
We can actually drill down on specific
features, too.
One of the pieces of feedback that we
got was actually talking about gesture
based support.
>> Right, because we had one person
who said that the swiping should be
more options, and we had one person who
said that the swiping should be delete.
>> That's right, or complete.
Yeah so, I certainly think that we
should probably strive to keep our UI
here very simple.
So I don't know that Perdema's
suggestions of revealing a panel behind
these screens is really going to be
the direction that we want to go in, but
I definitely think gesture based support
is something that we need to investigate
with a higher fidelity prototype.
>> Right, and when I'm thinking
about that gesture based support,
we can rely either on what we expect
users to have already seen in
other apps or
we can have an instructional thing.
We have this, mock over here, we have
a place that we can have information
that's just sort of
an overlay on this screen.
>> Yeah.
>> We could have that inform users about
how to swipe and
how to complete a task if we wanted to.
>> I think that's something that we're
going to have to test a little bit more,
too.
Because anecdotal evidence suggests too,
that some of these splash screens,
that it prevents people from
actually engaging in the app.
>> Oh, I see.
>> So
sometimes they want a little
more serendipitous discovery.
Pradema for instance,
was very willing and
very tolerant of just playing
with an app to see how it worked.
Whereas I think Hugh was a little
bit more regimented in his need.
>> Yeah, Hugh wanted it to be,
if it's a to-do list app,
we should be able to
check things off quickly.
>> That's right.
That's right.
What were some of the other
feedback that we got?
>> Well, first off,
we got some positive feedback, right?
>> Yeah, that's always good.
>> We got that the,
when we ask people to make a new event,
both of the testers they
went straight to these fabs.
Especially on these two screens,
they just went straight for that fab.
That's exactly what we'd hoped for and
the affordances were clearly
big enough for those.
>> Yeah.
>> Smaller than this affordance.
>> Yeah, the one question that did come
up is maybe this affordance is just
a little bit too big.
>> Yeah, because it might cover up.
I can't see whether it's just one
person going to this event or
multiple because one of them
might be under the fab.
>> Yeah, that's right.
So we might actually be having a little
bit of an issue with hiding some of
the data there.
But I agree, that positive feedback
is really encouraging that
at least the users are able to pick
up where the fat is and what it does.
They all clearly understood
that that was event creation.
>> We also got feedback that was
something we weren't looking for
originally, which is both of our
testers, we had them expect to be able
to click on this and open a screen like
this but that shows current details.
>> Um-hm.
>> And we actually didn't mock that up.
>> That's true, we did not.
One of the other things that just
caught my eye in our design here and
perhaps something that
led to Hugh's confusion.
If you look here,
we call this thing a task.
If you look here, we call it a task.
But if you look here in this
screen we call it an event.
>> That's true actually.
That is a thing that I
hadn't thought about because
as we were designing this we were
thinking of those as the same object.
>> That's right.
>> We were thinking
this is a task/event.
>> And
I guess we don't communicate anymore.
That's a thing that we expect.
We sort of had an expert
blind spot there.
>> Yep, yep, that definitely happened.
Well we're going to have to correct,
rectify that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Maybe involving a tech writer in this
project would be a good idea if we have
access to one.
>> Right.
>> But, that might cost
a little bit of money, so
maybe we should just keep an eye for
consistency.
>> So, as another option we might be
able to present the same flow with maybe
all of these say events, or
all of these say task, or
some other word that might
communicate all of that and
just see is Hugh able to figure that
out, is Pardema able to figure that out,
is anyone else that we have in our
office able to figure that out?
>> Yeah,
I think that's a great suggestion,
not only testing some of
the UI components, like for
instance where the fab was, or
whether or not there's a hero element.
But testing the language of the app
is a really important part of
bringing the highest
fidelity to our experience.
We really want that measure of
consistency through our app for
our users.
>> Right.
All right.
So wow, we've got a lot of feedback and
we've got a lot of things
that we can iterate on.
I think right now it's time to take
a quick look at this feedback and
think about what is actionable.